- (laughs) That's the good stuff.
I was going around on the internet
when I came across these mud jeans.
I mean, they look like
a normal pair of jeans,
but they are pre-dirtied
so that you can put them on
and immediately look like
you've done a hard day's work.
I've found myself outside
on a few occasions,
but I'm definitely not
a get your hands dirty,
let's build a barn, type of person.
Yeah, I'm kinda envious of that lifestyle.
I wish I could maybe be
a little more outdoorsy.
Oh God, they're so dirty.
Like, oil spill meets demolition derby.
Oh no.
These pair of jeans are $425.
I wish I could pull that
off, but there's no way.
Hey, so we're gonna go try and find
some denims to DIY our
own inexpensive version,
so let's go.
Looks like we found the pants.
We've got the denim outfit.
We're gonna dirty this up.
Let's do this.
Okay, so we have our denim suit.
We have our blank slate here.
I think it's time we try to get this
as dirty as the expensive one.
But first, it'd be a real shame
if we got our hands dirty.
Let's get started.
Alright, so we're gonna
take this mixture here.
A lot of pocket work, as they
say in the fashion world.
I think it looks pretty cool.
Go ahead and dirty up the knees.
Rub that bleach in.
These jeans are, they're gonna smell good.
I think we are going to graduate
to just brown shoe polish.
Yeah, I worry I should
have worn dirtier socks.
I'm just rubbing dirt on me.
But the look, to be fair,
we're definitely getting there.
I mean, this absolutely
looks real 'cause it is.
This also looks real.
And the pants, I mean,
I think we're definitely
coming pretty close
to replicating the $900 outfit.
This is our denim recreation,
and I think we did a pretty good job.
I am pretty amazed at how this turned out.
This looks real.
This looks like I actually
had a terrible accident.
This smells way worse.
The other one just
smells like new clothes.
This smells like a garbage disposal.
You can buy a jacket and regular jeans,
and I think you can get
that sort of rugged,
dirty look on your own without
literally spending a
month's rent on one outfit.
I'm the same person I was before.
I'm a phony.
I gave it a valiant effort.
Medically, it looks like
something's wrong with me.
The expensive ones still look like mud.
This looks like I poop out of the front.
I don't know.